blessings be with you all
ladies and gentlemen
i will read out the political agreement
that will be
signed immediately after being read out
to you
in the name of allah the almighty the
merciful
political agreement
as we have felt the hovering danger over
our country
and the threats to the transitional
period
and in the wake of the continued
conflict among the political forces
undermining our country's unity and
stability
and since all the initiatives have
failed to address the recent political
impasse which led
the armed forces chief commander to take
certain measure
on the 25th of october last
and considering that the
political crisis requires a great deal
of
wisdom and sense of patriotic
responsibilities
therefore both the parties to this
document have pledged to work together
to restore the democratic courts and to
serve the country's national interest
and also to avoid plunging into the
unknown or harming the country's unity
peace or security and in order to
complete the transitional period until
we reach an elected
civil government which cannot be
achieved in the absence of
harmony among all the political forces
the youth
women resistance committees the nomads
the displaced and the refugees
and in order to exit the current
political crisis and on the basis of the
resolution made by the armed forces
chief commander it is agreed upon the
following
it is agreed and emphasized that the
2019 constitutional document
as amended in 2020 shall form the basis
for completing the transitional period
taking into consideration the special
status of the eastern part of the sudan
which should be addressed within a
national context to maintain our
territorial integrity and ensure peace
and security satisfactory to fellow
sudanese in the east
second the set constitutional document
shall be amended under mutual agreement
to ensure the inclusion of all the
parties with the exception of the
former ruling party the national
congress
third the existing civil military power
sharing during the current transitional
period is a linchpin to sudan security
and stability
such partnership should be maintained
under strict commitment to forming a
civil
technocratic government
fourth
the interim sovereignty council shall
continue to oversee the transition
as envisaged under article 8 of the
constitutional document without
intervention in the executive process
fifth power shall be transferred as
scheduled
to an elected civilian government
six the transitional period shall be
governed by a political declaration
defining the manner of power sharing and
partnership among all the parties the
military civil forces provincial
administrations the youth women
revolutionaries and the religious
dignitaries
seventh
the recent
incident that took place during protests
including death and injuries of both
military and civilians should be
under investigations on all found guilty
should be
brought to justice and tried before
courts
eighth the juba agreement for peace
shall be put into force and all the
non-signatory parties shall join ninth
to speed up
reinstating the state institutions by
way of forming the legislative council
the constitutional
court
and also appointing the chief justice
and chief prosecutor
other institutions shall be formed or
reinstated immediately within
specific time limits
10th
a national dialogue inclusive and
transparent shall be initiated
encompassing all the political societal
and revolutionary forces as a step
towards forming the constitutional
conference 11th it is agreed upon the
necessity to restructure the committee
responsible for
disbanding and eliminating the remnants
of the foreign regime and the relevant
professionals and experts be brought
forward to enable such committee to
perform effectively and justly
and to have its decisions reviewed and
appealed in accordance with the law
all political detainees shall be
released
thirteen
efforts shall be exerted towards forming
a one uniform and unified national army
14th
by way of signing this political
agreement the decision made by the chief
command of the armed forces relieving
the interim prime minister from office
shall be reversed
signed by general abdulfatah al-buruhan
chairman of the sovereignty council and
dr abdullah hamduk the interim prime
minister
the document ends and now it's time
for signing ceremony
[Applause]
foreign
ladies and gentlemen now we give the
floor
to the doctor
the interim prime minister
[Music]
chairman of the sovereignty council
the deputy chairman members of the
council
leaders of the executive popular and
political forces ladies and gentlemen
may god's peace and blessings be upon
you all
glory and mercy to the fallen martyrs
the fallen the martyrs of the revolution
who made this moment possible
i should begin saying
that
our country
the sudan
is guarded
and preserved
by
of
restoring
country back on course
the most glorious moment following that
of the independence
was then
when we came together
united in october 1964 april 1985 and
december
2018
when i then
accepted
the designation
as an interim prime minister i realized
that
the road was not strewn with roses it
would be
a daunting
task
however
fraught by risks
and dangers however by joining hands we
can all
reach
a peaceful shore
we can all prevent our country from
plunging
into the unknown we should all come
together
to
let the people decide who will take and
hold
the reigns of power
this framework political agreement will
open doors to address
all the pending
issues of the transitional period over
the past two years
and under
this partnership
we have managed to achieve a lot
we've brought back sudan into the within
the international community lifted its
name from the terrorist blacklist and
many
achievements however we still have many
challenges laying ahead but by our unif
unity and strong will
we can march forward as i sign this
document
i am guided by four basic principles one
we
put we must put an end to bloodshed
i know our people are capable of
sacrificing however each drop of blood
is precious let's put an end
to the blood bath and let's spare each
and every drop of blood
this agreement will
break the tension
and take us through the bottleneck
we will restore the democratic courts
until we achieve permanent and lasting
democracy
also
this document paves the way
for all of us
to maintain and preserve the
achievements we had at over the past two
years
whether in peace or in economy this is a
very important
point
to bear in mind
third
this agreement
well
fortify our efforts towards
a civil democratic transformation
within our neighborhood and within the
regional international community we
thank all those who lent a helping hand
and we are prepared to work together
to march forward
thank you once again
and may god's peace and blessings be
upon you all
and the chief commander of the armed
forces
the name of allah
the almighty the merciful
i
salute you
my fellow countrymen in each and every
corner of the country
you deserve all appreciation
you set examples
of sacrifice
and fortitude i salute you
as you honor your revolution
i salute you
as you defend your revolution and this
moment represents a clear defense of the
revolution we salute all
who have made efforts for preserving
this moment and
also we extend all
appreciation to all our brothers and
friends
who stood by our side
since the beginning of this political
crisis
it has been long
and today we believe by signing this
political document we are paving the way
for a true democratic transitional
period as pictured by ourselves and by
the people
and as what you invested
at the beginning of april 2019 we thank
all the sudanese people and all the
efforts and sacrifices made by our
fellow sudanese we are adamant to remain
united remain
harmonious
and it is our customs
to have our own
differences resolved
amongst ourselves
i also extend all thanks and
appreciation to those who have been
exerting maximum efforts
following october 25th
they have been working day and night to
have this crisis resolved many of our
friends
were
acting as intermediary
and
exerting all maximum
efforts including
made it necessary for me to take action
on the transition and take the actions i
had taken in the past
once again i extend all thanks
to dr abdullah he
has always
within
he has always
the subject of our confidence and
respect
meanwhile
we are aware of all the sacrifices made
by all the sudanese people and in order
to end
and preserve
any drop of blood
we will continue to work towards
preserving the transitional period until
all your dreams of democracy peace and
justice are achieved
over the past five or six days
a group among ourselves have been
maximum efforts including uh our brother
abdullahim hamdan who has
done
all in his power
together with
all the credit goes to them
for reaching this
agreement and we believe that this will
pave away the way
for a totally and complete transitional
period
and no party will be excluding with the
exception of the former ruling party the
national congress we will give the floor
and room to all the political forces to
take part in the process and once again
i extend all thanks and appreciation to
my fellow sudanese and pray to god
almighty to accept in his mercy the
fallen martyrs and i pray finally that
god will guide our steps forward to
march forward until we reach a
transparent democratic election and
peacefully and safely
cross towards total civilian government
and total democracy
thank you to all
behind this
namely dr abdullah
who was not far from us
he has been close
he has been patient
with us and
with him we have reached to this moment
thank you to you all
you're watching al jazeera we're in
sudan when an agreement's just been
reached and signed to reinstate deposed
leader abdullah handok as prime minister
we've been hearing from general
abdulfatah al-buhan who led the military
takeover of the
sovereignty council as it was
just a few months ago and saw the
ousting of abdullah hamdok as prime
minister just as i say a few weeks ago
previous to that prior to that we heard
from abdullah handok himself who has
been returned as prime minister of sudan
i want to bring in marwan bushara who is
our
senior political analyst marwan you've
been following the story for a long time
let's just talk about what the two
gentlemen were saying there first of all
what stood out for you
well first of all uh there are no
prepared remarks i mean a lot of it
seems to be improvised in a way
uh two the importance of the event is
the event itself
nothing that was said was that important
it seems to me what was not said
is more important than what was said
which is how did we get here
it seems like both leaders wanted at
every cost to avoid talking about what
just went down the last few weeks
general burhan
apparently again improvising
just said that well i had to do
what i had to do
because there was a political impasse
that i need to take care of
does that really justify a push of that
nature that we saw of course not there's
a bit too
surrealism to the event i must say
because as you said following this thing
over the past a few weeks at least not
to say months and years
clearly the general um
you know no longer smug as he was a few
weeks ago after the
coup
uh
has basically backtracked on everything
how did he backtrack why did he
backtrack
on the what pressure is it the pressure
of the street is it the pressure of the
international community is it the
pressure of his own allies
in the region of course
we're not really sure i can analyze that
but we're not really sure so clearly
both leaders wanted to move forward so
prime minister hamduk and i was a bit
surprised uh by his uh
you know light remarks about what is
what's gone down and basically saying
look let's move forward let's end the
blockchain i think of course that's a
very responsible statement from the
prime minister
i'm not sure whether the street is
listening or will be listening because
clearly for most people on the street of
sudan like a lot of us observers
will be asking the question what
guarantees are there that the military
are going to respect this agreement
certainly they did not they respect the
last one
let's talk about the reaction on the
streets because obviously earlier on we
were seeing uh crowds of people
we're
being told it was thousands but we don't
know how many thousands in comparison to
the size of a city like khartoum and
certainly a country like sudan that
could make a significant difference but
the abdullah hamduk said we must put an
end to the bloodshed as you mentioned do
you think this is going to be enough to
satisfy the people who've been out on
the streets well look one of the most
important things i have to say about
this as an observer as an analyst is
that this is a situation in flux this is
an evolving situation this is an event
that is part of a process we are now in
the midst of the process i do not
from my experience looking at situations
like that i do not believe this is the
end of this story
absolutely not
so clearly the prime minister maybe he
got some assurances from somewhere
whether it is from washington paris
cairo i don't know where
that you need to start moving forward
and as we move forward we try to figure
out what to do because i think it was
point
i can't remember exactly which point is
it but i think it was probably uh point
uh six or seven that said something
about that we're gonna be looking at the
at the transition as we move forward
so this is definitely gonna be an
evolving situation depending on
the uh the balance of power and in this
sense
straight to your question
the street is going to have a lot of
weight and clearly the straight had had
a lot of influence over the last few
weeks the bloodshed did not come from
the street of course the bloodshed
mostly come from the
from the from the security forces
one of the most incredible thing about
what happened in sudan over the past two
years
is that this has been
in its essence a peaceful revolution
what we saw in 2019 and in 2020 and what
we've seen just the last few days are
sudanese basically going out with their
own bare bodies
trying to protect their achievement
their revolution and the military was
basically square so once again i would
say the following
there is a pressure from the street but
there's also and i must underline that
because
it's important to talk about other
issues when we underline that whether
when the international community wants
to put pressure
the pressure works
when the united states when europe
when the african union put pressure on
the military in sudan it worked
so when we look at other situations
let's say i don't know tunisia for
example or other places in the middle
east clearly international pressure
coupled with popular pressure
does bear fruit and the 180 percent 180
sorry 180 degrees
uh reversal by the general sudan is a
testimony that non-violent popular
pressure works that the international
community has a role to play that the
likes of the united states that says
that we put human rights and democracies
at the center of our foreign policy when
they actually deliver on that
there are results as we've seen today in
khartoum marwan stay with me i want to
speak to samahira mubarak she's a
spokeswoman for the sudanese
professionals association i believe
she's joining us now on the line from
khartoum thank you very much indeed for
being with us i don't know if you had a
chance to hear either of the speeches
that were being made at the signing
ceremony i just want to ask you what you
made of what was going on
well uh for us any any stat that's going
to keep the military in
power that's going to keep the military
uh having a political role it's totally
refused sudanese people have been out on
the streets
stating that we want the military back
in the barracks this is what we have
been saying since october the 25th it's
the voice of the people that's going to
make the difference
with all these agreements and everything
that's still going to keep the military
in power is for us totally of no regard
uh we are now out on the streets there
are protests all over sudan and for us
this is totally uh refused this is not
going to put an end to bloodshed because
if it would have put an end to bloodshed
it would have done that in august 2019
the bloodshed after august 2019 proved
that the military is not to be trusted
for the security or the lives of the
sudanese people
for us we stated it clear we want the
military out of the political life in
sudan we will not recognize and we will
not deal and all the negotiations and
what has resulted out of it for us is
absolutely of no regard
if the military does not step down in
the way that you would like if this is
the situation in sudan going forward
what would you want to see from the
transitional council as it is at the
moment with abdullah
at as prime minister with the general uh
general abdul fattah al-burkham at its
head what would you want to see from
them as if you like a gesture of good
faith and dedication that they are
prepared to try to move the situation
forward
first there is no gesture of good faith
after the bloodshed this for this is
what's done it's done we are we have
uh we want the lives of the 40 martyrs
that have died in in the past month to
come back can they offer that this is a
gesture of could say
why the coup from the beginning if we're
going to go back to where we stop work
to the partnership
for us now it's high time that we move
on to complete civilian rules
if they want to
give us a gesture of good faith
give us back the lives of the 14 martyrs
that we've lost in the past 20 days give
us back the health of the injured and
all what we have gone through in the
past month
this military coup and this combination
that we have seen is a failed
combination it's not to be trusted we do
not
want the military in the political life
in sudan anymore this partnership for us
is done it's just collapsed totally
collapsed and there's no way of
performing
there is obviously going to be a period
during which people are going to be
waiting to see what the next move of
this transitional council as it exists
at the moment will be how long do you
think people
in sudan are prepared to wait
before
their patience runs out
well we've this revolution has been
ongoing for the past three years i think
we have a lot of patience and we have a
lot uh
of patience and and and will
our will is beyond uh that we go back
right now and there's too much bloodshed
that has taken place for us to step back
now
uh it's not it's not that simple and
apart from that we have given this
entire uh coup and whatever has resulted
out of it illegitimate for us
at the end of the day it's what the
people of sudan want and we have
continued and continued this fight and
we will continue this struggle until we
realize our complete transition our
complete civilian
transition and we have uh stated it's
clear we went out in 2018 against the
dictatorship for us
all the signs that we have seen in the
past
month in the past 20 plus days have
shown that there is no way
that we can trust the military to be
part of the power
again we cannot trust the military to
not retaliate
on the activists on the political
leaders it's for us a matter of
of being or not being anymore
and we are
and i believe and we have proven that we
are willing to to go along however long
it takes
setbacks we've always come back and
we're very diligent and we're very
determined that we want this
transformation to take place and we want
this transformation
to take out all
militarization of the political and
civil life incident out of the picture
this is the only way that we can
transform into a complete democracy
is by washing out the military we've
given the military enough time
to step back
it it came to the table with the fact
that it's going to provide
security it failed at us it came to the
table with the fact that it's going to
be a guard off the transition and it
felt twice in doing that it failed in
the massacre of june 3rd in 2019 and
again it failed in october on october
the 25th in 2021. there is no third
chance
we know that enough is enough i was
talking to al jazeera senior political
analyst bashar he was describing in his
assessment that this had been
um to all intents and purposes a
peaceful revolution it had been a series
of peaceful protests what violence there
had been he said had come from the side
of the military if you are if the people
on the streets are not getting what they
want from this structure of this
transitional council how far do you
think people are prepared to go to
change things
the most unique thing about the movement
in sudan is that it's peaceful the most
uh
we we have come to to a realization that
that this theme of peaceful protest of
peaceful demonstration however long it
takes
is
where we all win at the end
if we slip into violence we know we we
know the cost of violence we've seen
that we've experienced civil wars before
with experience the the separation in
our country before and we know how how
high that cost is and that's why we know
that despite the violence coming from
from the military side and from the
security side the different security
forces in power
yes we know that the cost
of
peaceful demonstrations is much slower
than slipping into violence and we are
all very well aware of that and that's
the that's that that's the secret
ingredient of our continuation and of
our content of our the stamina of the
civilization revolution
samhain al-babar we appreciate you
joining us on al-jazeera mum thank you
very much indeed for your time
well the agreement we've just seen
signed comes after weeks of violence
scenes in khartoum and other parts of
the country sudan's military and
civilian leaders had been sharing power
since long-time leader omar bashir was
removed from office in 2019 but in the
months that followed both sides blamed
each other for slow reforms a worsening
economic crisis and corruption that's
led to big divisions in the transitional
government
the situation got worse last month after
general abdulfatah al-buhan dissolved
the interim government and detained
civilian leaders now in the past few
minutes the newly reinstated prime
minister abdullah hamduk spoke at the
presidential palace and ways to take the
country forward
when i first accepted the designation as
interim prime minister i realized the
road was not strong with roses it would
be a daunting task brought by risks and
danger however by joining hands we can
all reach a peaceful place we can all
prevent our country from plunging into
the unknown we should all come together
to let these people decide who will take
and hold the reigns of power
okay i want to bring in al jazeera
senior political analyst again bashar
he's been with us on set through all of
this we heard samahiro mubarak saying
that really there's the only solution is
one that allows us to all win in the end
but given the circumstances given what
we're hearing that seems like a long way
off
yes as i said we are in a situation
that's evolving we're on a flux
and i don't think what we heard today is
the last word if anything everything we
heard today
is so vague that it opens up
different doors to different possible
scenarios
but clearly now
what we've seen today in the last few
days is now the momentum is on the side
of the street the momentum now is on the
side of the civilian component of the
establishment in sudan clearly the
generals are on the defensive otherwise
they wouldn't have done
this really embarrassing 180 degrees
reversal of their position
clearly there's a pressure from the
street clearly there's pressure from the
international community clearly there is
an important indispensable pressure
from the african neighbors from the
african union and all of that is
important i just need to underline two
issues one
that the military has been the military
generals in particular i'm talking about
they've been they are part of the old
regime i mean let's not fool ourselves
about that they broke away from
al-bashir when they realized that there
was such a momentum in 2019 that they
said they're going to join the civilian
forces
two generals in this case they say they
are going to make the change and they
let the push under the name of democracy
no democracy is made through military
coup the way we've seen it
three i think it's important to note
to underline even that the last year or
so it was the military it was the
generals who were in charge on the uh
over the economic
policies and decision making not the
civilian government so clearly if there
are any troubles in sudan over the last
year economic and otherwise is the
responsibility of the military council
not the government two i think what
we've seen from the government was some
important achievements in breaking out
of the international isolation
bringing saddam back into the fold and
allowing sudan to to get hold of over
two billion dollars of foreign aid seven
hundred and seven hundred million of
which was frozen when the kutida
happened so clearly the generals are on
the defensive
clearly the generals are have been
mistaken clearly the generals in their
assessment that this could go through if
they could only maintain uh power for
for a few days and change some of the
decor in the in the sovereignty council
everything will be okay everything is
not okay as we've heard from the
activists
in in khartoum and that's very important
that after 10 11 years of
arab uprisings arab revolutions and so
forth clearly the example of sudan is
turning out to be
an example to follow in the sense that
people power
peaceful
on the street
more pressure and more pressure and more
pressure and try to bring as many
parties together as possible in building
coalition is the way forward not only in
sudan but
in the region in general
roman just bear with me for a second
because i want to talk to russel zelda
he's talking to us live now from
khartoum at the presidential palace
where that signing took place russell
what kind of atmosphere was there when
the signing was taking place and tell us
who was there but perhaps more
importantly who was not there
well
the atmosphere
was quite tense here and even
symbolically you can see that there were
three men uh just sitting in front of
the camera to sign a new agreement and
two of them are the members of the
military and even we can say one of the
members of the military and the other
one is the head of a strong paramilitary
group uh in sudan which is called the
for the the rapid support forces mr
hamate himself so we can see that the
balance of disney's every news new
agreement is quite in favor of the
military and that is heavily affected
and dominated by the military and we
could see that in today uh mr hamduk was
not quite happy about it but it was
rather a a stab that taken based on the
feeling of the responsibility and also
during uh mr abdulfatal burham's speech
also we have seen that he has thanked uh
mr hamduck several times and underlining
that he did that that that great
achievement has been made through the
negotiations and also based on mr
hamdu's good will however here there are
lots of uncertainties the people that we
are talking uh to here the people who
are close to mr abdullah hamduk and also
even to the sovereignty council they say
that there are several uncertainties in
this agreement we can see that the
constitutional declaration is still
going to be the base uh for the
transitional pay period however the
constitutional declaration that has been
signed is going to be amended
also under the mutual agreement for the
inclusion of the all parties we do not
know what what is going to be what are
going to be the points of this new
agreement and the the the power sharing
between the army and the civilians is
still the backbone of this agreement and
the sovereignty council is still going
to be in charge of overseeing all of the
decisions or the during this
transitional period which gives a
tremendous amount of power to the army
over this the government of technocrats
led by
abdullah hamduk and also
the power shall be it says that the
power shall be transferred to a civilian
government
as scheduled but however it's not clear
what is going to be the schedule what's
going to be the date of a fair and free
election for now in a previous interview
that i have conducted with mr abdul
fattah al-burun he said that
the election is going to be uh taking
place uh in uh 2023 however in this new
agreement the date is not specified and
also
a new political declaration is going to
be uh defined and announced later and
that is going to define the manners of
power sharing and the partnership of all
of the parties so that's also still not
clear and the political detainees are
going to be released that is one thing
that is clear and all parties are
agreeing on and that was one of the main
condition of the international community
from the usa european union and the
united nations as well the juba peace
agreement is going to be in place and
also be uh be implemented the
legislative council and the any
formation of the constitutional court is
one of the items among the agreement the
lack of a constitutional
court in the country is regarded as one
of the failure of the previous
government and that is quite important
because the country now officially
doesn't have any constitutional uh the
court and all the inclusive dialogue
that is going to be um to be initiated
to encompass in all the political and
societal forces the message definitely
to the streets because as of now as this
disagreement is signed we can see that
people are still protesting while
getting into the presidential palace
when the security forces left us to get
in the presidential palace we could see
that thousands of people are in front of
the presidential palace and chanting and
saying they'd reject this agreement and
even many of them were saying that they
feel that abdullah is betraying that we
do not know whether this agreement is
going to ease the tension industry
de-escalate the situation in the country
or not but as of now there are still
protests and police are using tear gas
and shooting in the air to disperse them
to remove them from the streets
particularly in front of the the the
presidential uh palace and also another
important
item of this agreement is is the the
investigation that shall be initiated on
the recent deaths and injuries that's
also one of the main
conditions of the international
community to investigate the deaths and
the killings that have been uh been
realized through the last
protest during these violent
confrontations and mr hamdu course has
been very much clear on that the the
blackjack in sudan must
must stop and also
forming a a new um
dismantling body also is going to be
important like reshaping and reformating
that also is going to be quite important
because the dismantling committee has
been formed to to to to remove the
elements of the previous regimes from
the system and now there will be some
amendments in that as well and their
fear are that this new committee
appointed members being appointed by
general after abraham could bring back
the old regime's elements as well
russell obviously a very complicated
complicated set of agreements we're
going to have to wait to see how that
pans out over the coming weeks and
months for now russell serda in khartoum
thank you very much indeed i want to go
to khali khayal she's the managing
partner of the think tank inside
strategy partners she's joining us by
skype from cartoon we've been talking to
her throughout this process
given what we have heard in the signing
of the agreement is there anything there
at all that gives you any optimism
[Music]
it's tough to say at the moment this
does seem like a massive compromise
and we know of course that the prime
minister is a compromiser and they have
managed to isolate him during his
households from his incubator but also
from the street and so i'm
dismayed but not surprised that he was
sort of pushed into this position i mean
looking at the footage from the signing
today he did seem to be
still very much the hostage that he was
until um this morning
the street has not been happy i think
that's that's and and it continues to
show its dismay at any sort of power
sharing agreement between the civilians
and the military because indeed that was
what they called for it wasn't merely
about the release of
the release of political prisoners it
was a much more um it was a much larger
conversation about what sudan's
political future looks like and frankly
it's not this
um and so you know we've seen several um
terms of this agreement being brought
out but there are still some questions
for example the sovereign council that
was set up after the coup and there was
very little mention of the the contents
of that sovereign council it has been
filled by members of the ncp regime and
islamists of other shades and there's no
there's nothing yet to indicate what
will happen to those uh members so
there's still a lot of questions that
need to be answered
we appreciate you being with us at al
jazeera throughout all this but for now
thank you very much indeed uh marwan
bashar al jazeera's senior political
analyst um final word from you is there
it seems as though we're entering into a
waiting phase now and the question is as
we were talking about earlier how long
the patience of the people
in sudan is going to last
well judging from the past two years
it's clearly they are patient and and
clearly what we hear from reports on the
ground is that they are willing uh to uh
to really uh you know wait it out if you
will but i think also the military is
more than capable of waiting everything
out as we know in the region but now
what we're talking about is not the
removal of the military but we're
talking about the generals in politics
how far can they go how
much of an influence should they have
and here and i just want to sort of take
what our uh correspondent said in
khartoum because i think what he said is
very important but i think there are two
ways of looking at what you saw today
one is take a still picture of it
if you take a still picture you will see
two generals and one civilian
the general is very confident still as
is and the prime minister is a bit the
civilian is a bit
shaken right so if you take that still
picture that still picture and you
listen to what they said clearly the
military still have the upper hand but
if you look at the video if you look at
more of a moving event you'll see that
the prime minister was under house
arrest just a few days ago that there
was a coup d'etat
that they thought they're going to get
away with it that they were remaking the
council and they were going to make a
new government and suddenly things
switched so if you look at the movement
not just at the still picture you will
see that perhaps the military is still
smug about certain things but clearly
the momentum is not moving in their
direction especially if the
international pressure continues and if
the if the street pressure continues as
well because in the end of the day
the last month has been a total fiasco
for the military why because they did
what they did and suddenly they had to
do 180 degrees return that doesn't mean
that the prime minister is suddenly the
ruler of the land but what it means is
that there is a momentum suddenly not in
favor of the generals but rather on the
favor of the street but as you said
we will see
where will this take us because there
are a number of dynamics in at play here
there's the military there's the street
there is the neighbors and the african
union and there is the international
community
al jazeera senior political analyst as
always marwan thank you very much indeed
we've been in sudan an agreement's just
been reached and signed to reinstate
abdullah as
the new prime minister or the returning
prime minister of sudan he was ousted
nearly a month ago when the military
seized power and that led to weeks of
protests and unrest across the nation